i mean we've had interest rates
declining for
more than 40 years at this point and
if you look at the long-term trends in
the asset markets
uh clearly there have been a a few bumps
along the way but it has been
a very steady rise basically since
interest rates peaked in 1981.
so but and that's and that's what i
really want to get to is
yes where is where do the parallels come
about
with the united states exactly what's
happening right now
exactly and and you're right it's
it's been quite an amazing long acid
bubble in the u.s there was a bit of a
blip 2008 2009 but the us was the first
to recover and it's for the same reasons
and so
um so we need to answer that question um
so let me just um outline the other two
scenarios so one is when banks lend for
asset purchases
and that creates asset inflation and
that can go on for many many years
as long essentially it's a big ponzi
scheme you know
it will continue as long as banks
continue to create
credit for asset purchases that's the
condition
the moment that stops is like this um
you know uh children's game where you go
around the
around the room and you've got the
chairs there musical chairs right and
while the music
is on they walk around but you've taken
away
one or two chairs they have to sit down
when the music stops and there aren't
enough chairs
and it's exactly that so you know
bankers have used this metaphor
essentially you know when
um who was it prince chuck prince said
the music is playing we're still dancing
you know
the music is there they're creating
credit we have to play the game and it's
rational
therefore for everyone to stay in the
game because you're earning money
but you also have to be aware the moment
the music stops
it's going to be a rush for the door
because there aren't enough seats
because asset prices will not rise
anymore and the late comers that bought
very
expensively and they need further
capital gains just to you know service
and repay the loans they won't get them
they will go bust you have
non-performing assets
and that then leads to this downward
spiral where the banks then restrict
lending further
which pushes down asset prices further
which creates more bankruptcies more
non-performing loans this of course what
happened in japan
but it's also what happened um in in
many other
countries um in europe we had the same
situation in ireland portugal spain and
greece for instance
in the 2000s so the second one is when
banks
create credit for consumption
now that's the one that most people
think of money creation money printing
inflation turns out that's only one of
three fundamental scenarios
and you know when we had the so-called
great moderation in the us
um there was a massive expansion in the
money supply
but there was no inflation there was no
consumer price inflation why
well it was money creation bank credit
creation for
asset purchases it was the acid bubble
it wasn't really a moderation it's just
that's where you had your inflation acid
inflation
but it is true that when banks create
credit for consumption
you will get consumer price inflation
that's something we need to talk about
because 2020
2021 uh this is you know the mechanism
is now in place for that to become
uh quite prominent thirdly though
there's a third scenario and this is
really the
the redeeming feature of the banking
system and it is why the u.s
economy really if you look look back for
200 years has been one of the strongest
economies
in the world and why other countries
that have also been very successful in
the last
200 years like germany and then last 100
years japan last
50 years china they've done the same
namely the following
you ensure that the majority of your
bank
credit your money creation in the
banking system bank credit creation
is used not for asset purchases is used
not for consumption
but is used for business investment
that's the the golden rule of banking if
you ensure that
most of bank credit creation money
creation is used for business investment
in productive
investments that expand productivity
implement new technologies
increase goods and services create new
products that have value
of course there will always be failures
but overall it's a very of a different
kind from
asset purchases property and finance or
consumption
you know so as long as that's the
majority of your money creation
is actually for business investment and
of course
the biggest employer in all these
countries also the us
are small firms small firms are the most
important employer
it's around 70 percent of employment
in in the us in the uk and japan and
germany
germany japan actually it's close to 80
percent even
now these small firms they always credit
ration they don't need bank loans
they can't use you know the stock market
and and so on
so they need bank lending and if you
have bank lending for productive
purposes
ideally to small firms you will get
economic growth and no inflation
that's quite quite an extraordinary
insight because
we can have very high growth
and no inflation there's almost no limit
to economic growth
hang on some people say hang on aren't
there limits to growth didn't the club
of rome tell us
you know climate change and all that
we've got limits to growth
well not really actually there's a lot
of misunderstandings clearly we should
all
be careful to to treat the environment
well and things like pollution
and environmental degradation is bad but
growth as such is not the enemy because
what is growth growth can't be the enemy
because growth is an accounting fiction
it's just an accounting fiction there is
no economic growth you know ask a
physicist
you know tell me what's economic growth
how is the economy growing the
physicists will tell you no there's no
growth we know that the laws of
thermodynamics you know it's all the
same you're just transforming energy
from one state to another
but there's no growth that can't be
growth so we've created this accounting
fiction by
taking out certain statistical series
putting them together we call it gdp the
national income accounts
and that's what we're monitoring but gdp
as such is not
hurting the environment you know it's
not um
it is bad activities that can hurt the
environment we should avoid those that's
you know that's fine but it doesn't mean
we have to have zero growth or negative
growth
so we can have actually very high growth
the us has shown that in the past when
it was an emerging market and was
growing at
very high economic growth rates china
has shown this for 40 years double-digit
economic growth um is possible and
they did it by making sure bank credit
was guided essentially mainly for
productive business investment they
they stepped in they said no bank credit
for asset purchases and no bank credit
for consumption
of course recently you know the last 10
years they've liberalized that
but that's how you get very high growth